- All right! I love scrolling
through the infinite pages
of social media to find the
stuff that makes us all smile,
and I love sharing it with you all.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
A woman in Stockholm, Sweden
has an unusual obsession
with a simple household item: safety pins.
And she's awesome.
And she makes fully functional
fashion pieces you can wear,
all with those little metal objects.
Here's a mask, which is so cool.
Here's a dress to match, 'cause why not?
And this is the artist wearing
one of her handmade jackets.
(audience gasps)
I know, see all the oohs, ahhs.
All those were good.
They were (indistinct)
It's how you feel.
She's put together her first collection,
she calls it Obsession.
And I'll tell you, I am obsessed.
It's such a talent.
Let's get Tonio on the line right now.
All right, what's on Tonio?
(audience applause)
- Hi
- Okay, so why, why safety
pins, I have to ask you?
It's lovely to meet you as well.
- Well, I just love
using an everyday object
and transforming it into
something completely different.
To put it in a situation.
It gets it to show off its beauty and
just transform it to something else.
And put it in a context where it's not
supposed to be, very unexpected.
And it's like kind of
a modern day pop art.
And I also love how shiny
the metal pieces are.
A few years ago,
I actually watched a lot of
Project Runway, and I felt
inspired to do my own
unconventional challenge.
So I ended up buying hundred
thousand safety pins,
and 500 hours after that,
I had created my first creation ever.
Which I ended up giving
away to a good cause.
- Oh my gosh.
It's so cool.
Reminds me, I don't
know if you saw Cruella?
The new Cruella?
But it reminds me of all those
dresses that like make on
that show. It's so inspiring.
It's so cool.
Can you tell us about
your Obsession collection?
- Yeah.
My collection contains 10
outfits and took 7,000 hours to
complete during one year.
It's called Obsession because it
was such an obsession.
I could not stop working with it
and it actually consumed me a little bit.
But I do love this art form and
I would love to do it full time.
So recently last year I
quit my full-time job as a
visual designer to pursue this
dream, to become an artist.
So now I'm hoping that I will
be able to support myself as
an artist in the future.
And I would love to travel
the world and have exhibitions
showcasing my artwork and
my avant garde fashion.
- Oh my God. Well man,
good luck to you, Tonio.
It's amazing.
It's truly, really cool.
Like what you're doing and I've
never seen anything like it.
I'm liking your post right now. Right?
All right?
All right,
Well that's not all our
season long partner pilot pin,
the go-to pin to the Kelly
Clarkson show likes to celebrate
those who create fearlessly,
just like you ma'am.
So they're going to be using
their friction erasable pen to
write you a check for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience applause)
You can buy, a ton of safety pins.
With a thousand dollars.